thank you for joining us today we're
really really excited to present
honeycomb and and some new features of
Android and also some really really
interesting demos we have a couple of
people getting on stage with us we have
we have a pretty good demo of the
Motorola Xoom tablet running honeycomb
and Hugo is gonna present that who's our
director of p.m. and after that Chris
yerga is gonna get on stage and talk
about some of the future functionality
and features of Android Market and we
have some really exciting news there as
well and and just briefly let me talk a
little bit about how excited I am about
the momentum it's a you know Android
obviously a you know being an
open-source project we consider
ourselves the shepherd of it and as we
Shepherd it through the industry we're
seeing it just pop up all over the place
at CES when I walked the floor it was
just amazing and surprising about all
the different variety of devices that
that popped up running Android again you
know with open-source you don't really
know what people are going to do with it
and you know all the innovation doesn't
happen in this building it happens all
around us so there's a lot of lot of
excitement and a lot of opportunity
future opportunity for finding Android
in new places when you see Hugo's demo
one of the things you're gonna you're
gonna witness is how Google's cloud
services tie together all these
different applications and all these
different companies that are making
devices in all these different segments
again it's the cloud that makes the
experience seamless you could literally
lose your laptop or lose your phone or
lose your your your tablet and all your
data is safe and secure in the cloud the
next time you pick up your your new
tablet it all comes back the cloud is
also the central point at which all the
applications and services share
information so in the future you'll be
able to see a real seamless integration
between phones and tablets and you know
Google TV which is also based on Android
and before I before I bring Hugo up the
one thing I wanted to mention is I truly
believe the Android team the folks over
in building 44
with all the android statutes out front
I really truly believe they're the
hardest working team in mobile they
sweat the details and they're there
right now actually putting the finishing
touches on what we're talking about
today so I really really would
appreciate it if you mention them when
you talk about Android because they're
the ones that are actually creating it
okay Hugo come on up and show off your
stuff thank you Andy and good morning
and welcome everyone from the very
beginning the Android project as Andy
said has been committed to open
development and one of the most critical
aspects of open development is creating
an ecosystem a platform that enables
developers to iterate and innovate as
quickly as possible so our approach with
Android has been to equip developers
with the best possible toolkit that we
can build and then simply get out of
their way so with honeycomb we're
enabling this style of rapid a child
development that the internet has been
used to for so many years on this new
generation of tablet sized mobile
computers so today I'm going to show you
some of the new features of this
platform that we've designed
specifically keeping in mind the
creation of amazing apps that are
optimized for tablets sized computers so
let me start by giving you an overview
of honeycomb and first what you'll see
is that we've revamped how you navigate
in a device with a larger screen like
this so if you look at the bottom left
of the screen you see that there's a
back button there's a home button and
there's also a new button that's
dedicated to multitasking so when I tap
that you'll see visual previews for some
of the applications that I was using
recently and it's and the state that
they're in so it's actually really easy
to switch back and forth over here on
the bottom right you'll see the
notifications and systems status area
which I'll talk about in just a little
bit and the rest of the screen is
dedicated entirely to applications and
the home screen is actually a really
important part of our developers story
it's not just a warehouse full of
apps it's an application development
platform in itself and I'll talk a
little bit about that
for example widgets as we call them and
by the way the widget system is the same
that's been hugely popular in Android
phones can now be backed by collections
of data and these collections of data
can be visualized in some interesting
ways so right here you're seeing my
Gmail inbox that I can scroll through
you also see my calendar I can even
scroll through them together and it's
just really easy with multi-touch
support if I move over here to this home
screen I have a grid widget for my
bookmarks and if I scroll once again I
have what we call a stack widget that
allows me to flick through different
things for example Major League Baseball
highlights or my books over here or some
YouTube videos that are popular today
and I can even sort of do this together
and actually have a lot of fun with it
so there you go
so these widgets are sort of reusable
pre-built components that developers can
use to bubble up important information
to the home screen from users
perspective what really matters is
despite all of the clever computer
science that we have to enable the
smooth experience that you just saw it's
really just about quick and easy access
to important information now another
thing that we've redesigned on Android
on on honeycomb is the notification
system and as you'll see notifications
are completely non intrusive they don't
get in your way
just like on phones but now they contain
more information so in this particular
case my friend Anand is IME me and you
can see his picture in the notification
and you can ignore it or you can action
it if you want what we've done is we've
built maybe I should tell him to stop
what we've done is we've built some
templates that actually allow developers
to create these richer more advanced
kind of notifications and I'll show you
a few of those probably my favorite
example is what I'm going to show you
now there's a headphone notification at
the bottom here
I happy was listening to some music
before getting on stage and while the
music app is active in the background I
get this notification that if I click on
will allow me to play pause or go to the
next track for example like this now if
I tap on the notifications area anywhere
here on the bottom right I'll be able to
dismiss some of these notifications if I
don't need them anymore we call this a
line-item veto and while I'm in the
neighborhood let me talk about the quick
settings panel right here this gives me
quick access to important things like
airplane mode Wi-Fi and so on and so
forth just right there in one place so
now I want to show you some of the new
application patterns that we've created
as part of the honeycomb UI framework
but before I do that let me just point
out the fact that we've spent a
significant amount of effort making sure
that existing Android applications run
really well on tablets in fact an app
that's been designed with our
recommended development guidelines is
going to work without any modifications
and one really well on Android and I
want to show you an example in fact one
of my all-time favorite games which is
of course fruit ninja so because I was
playing this earlier I'm gonna see that
it's actually showing up here in my
recents by touching the multitasking
button so I'm gonna go into fruit ninja
and I'll play this for a little bit now
this is a completely unmodified version
of fruit ninja in fact what's available
in android market today before it was
built before honeycomb even existed and
it works amazingly well it even supports
multi fingered multi handed gestures if
you want you can probably also tell that
I am really good or getting really good
with this but I'll pause that for a
second so it works really well even
though it was built before honeycomb
even existed as I said now of course we
want to encourage application developers
to build tablet optimized experiences
for the applications and to do that
we've added a lot of really cool new
things to the honeycomb application
framework one of these things is what we
call an application fragment and I want
to show you what that is inside of Gmail
so let me open Gmail over here so we
we're in landscape mode and in landscape
mode you're gonna see two panes the left
folder view and then my inbox on the
right now watch what happens when I
click on a message when I tap on a
message you see that the leftmost pane
slid out to make room for another pane
the message that then slides into the
same place and if I click on the inbox
you see that the side the leftmost panel
or pane slides back in these panes are
what we call application fragments and a
fragment is something that a developer
can use to encapsulate specific
application functionality and then reuse
that throughout the application so for
example if I flip this tablet into a
portrait mode I may want and probably
will want to recombine how these
fragments are laid out and eventually
fragments are going to be useful so that
you can have completely reusable
functionality between the phone and the
tablet version of your application so
that's coming in the future another
really cool action is being able to pick
up and then drag a message for example
into a folder and this is something that
has been built not as part of Gmail but
part of the application framework we
have an incredibly full-featured
dragging manager that allows you to
create and manage sort of these dragging
interactions there's a lot more coming
there and then one last thing that I
wanted to show is across the top here is
the application bar the application bar
is another application pattern that can
be packaged into a fragment and in this
case it contains it's showing global
actions so I have search I have compose
and a few other things but if I select a
few messages you'll see that that
application bar now changes to contain
actions that are specific to the
selected items in this case archive Star
label etc
so this is another example of the really
modular development that we've built as
part of the honeycomb application
framework go back to the home screen now
I want to talk a little bit about
performance needless to say we've spent
a tremendous amount of time really
optimizing performance at every level on
honeycomb especially for 2d and 3d
graphics so first all of 2d drawing that
developers have been doing with the
existing framework can now be hardware
accelerated and developers can actually
do that literally by adding just one
line of code to their existing
application and then they get they can
take advantage of hardware acceleration
we've also added a new animation
framework to honeycomb to enable
developers to add transitions and
overall polish to their applications
then you've seen some of that stuff
already in the home screen I want to
show in a really simple way how powerful
this is so I'm gonna click on the top
button here on the right that's gonna
take me into the home screen
customization UI and then I'm gonna tap
on the home button on the bottom left
and then I'll do that in rapid sequence
and you can see how amazingly powerful
this new animation framework is just
incredibly fluid and smooth we're also
introducing a brand new graphics engine
called render script render script is
built for high-performance interactive
3d graphics and it enables some amazing
new things some of which I believe
you've already seen let me show you one
of the best examples of this which is
YouTube so I'm gonna go into YouTube
here and what you see is this insanely
beautiful 3d video wall that I can use
to browse videos on YouTube and you can
see how fluid and awesome it is to play
with this is built using render script
I'll go into our books app and in the
books app you'll see a 3d carousel of
the books that are purchased also built
with vendor script and if I go into a
book here I've chosen unbroken watch how
incredibly smooth the turning the page
flipping animation is even when you have
pictures it's just really beautiful this
is all built using renders
technology as well just for fun I want
to show you just a few more examples of
3d applications that we can build or
that can be built on honeycomb we've
spent as much time as we could
optimizing performance at every level
even doing things like supporting multi
multi processor cores or multi-core
processors at the kernel level to make
sure that everything works super
smoothly so let me take maps as an
example so I'll go into maps here and
with the diversion of maps as some of
you may know we we're adding a dynamic
rendering technology with
three-dimensional vector graphics and
what that allows is for me to do
manipulations of all sorts and a map so
I can zoom I can do some rotations for
example I can tilt the map and if I can
go close I can even start to see some
buildings look how beautiful it is to
look at the Embarcadero just incredibly
cool I will also show our music
application which is over here and I'll
go to I'll go over here so look at this
incredibly smooth sort of car sale that
allows me to browse through my albums
also build using the the 3d constructs
that are part of the application
framework and one last and really fun
example is Google body which is a new
application that I've heard some called
the Google maps of human anatomy and I
can do here this you know things that
you would expect from for maps like pan
and zoom I can also turn on layers but
in these case they are layers like
muscles or maybe the circulatory system
or skeleton and I can zoom in here and
perhaps this is useful maybe tell my
doctor on the phone that I've broken my
clavicle or if my doctor tells me that
maybe I've pulled my infraspinatus I can
actually find out what that is
doesn't look that serious so speaking of
3d 3d graphics I wanted to invite an
expert over to the stage so please
welcome Thomas Williamson from wardroom
studios to show some of the amazing
amazing things that you can bill
using 3d graphics on Honeycomb Thomas
come on up Thank You Hugo my name is
Thomas Williamson I'm a CEO of wardroom
studios we're a game developer based out
of Gainesville Florida and where
recently we've moved completely over to
mobile development and next-generation
game development on Android so we have a
few games I want to show you the first
game is monster madness that's on the
first tablet here
okay so monster madness is a Southie
games title that was a ps3 game and
we've brought it over to Android using
the same assets the same gameplay logic
the same animations and you kind of get
a cinematic feel
and so the game itself is it's a
hack-and-slash shooter you have up to
two peoples again Wi-Fi call with two
different tablets fighting enemies
coming from all around you hundreds of
particles you have explosions I have
destructible environments you're below
up the barrel then there goes so you
have a lot of performance in high
definition
context with master Madison the games
gonna feature five huge environments
four difficulty levels vehicular combat
the whole nine yards real china store
everything we can't the player and the
high performance of android and what
honeycomb provides allows us to do that
so let's move on to the second template
and i can show you great battles
medieval so great battles medieval is a
history channel presents great battles
and it is a cooperative development Wien
war drum studios and slithering software
and so this title is basically an
educational strategy game with massive
battles and it's the first title that
we've done has a hundred percent usage
of two cores on tablet or or you know
we're looking sporting the phones as
well the game itself shows hundreds of
units animating moving uniquely thinking
all in a massive battle all on your
phone all on mobile just try to get it
so it really pushes the tablets to the
limit and you can look forward to all
both of these titles within the next
month thank you for your time Thank You
Thomas that was that was absolutely
stunning finally I'd like to talk a
little bit about the new media
capabilities of the honeycomb platform
some live multitasking here so I want to
show you the new camera app that we've
built because it has a completely
stunning new UI so as you can see here
on the right we have a really slick new
UI for it to expose all the controls
that you want when you're taking a
picture so I can you know control the
flash white balance and exposure
settings color effects etc I can also
flip to the front camera if I want I'll
go back to the main camera and I'll just
take a picture of you guys over there so
there you go and I can of course also
shoot a video and upload it instantly to
YouTube we think this is a really cool
new UI and hopefully you'll love it now
Android has also been an amazing
communications platform and this device
has a front-facing camera which is
really great because honeycomb supports
video chat so I want to show you a
little bit of video video chat and what
you won't see here necessarily because
the tablet is sort of fixed in a stable
position is that we've actually spent a
lot of time building image stabilization
technology as part of video chat on
honeycomb both to make the experience
really smooth but also to save bandwidth
recognizing that a lot of times users
are going to be on satoru networks with
with a device like this and it works
really really well to show you video
chat I'm going to actually contact my
friend Ladykiller Ladykiller is his
nickname you probably already know who
it is and you certainly will know as
soon as we connect so let's let's see if
we can talk to lady Keeler here it's
like you might not be online let me
you're going to talk maybe we'll try
logging out
oh I'm not signed in there you go that
would help so what I'll do here from
from my home screen is I'm gonna use a
widget that's called a contact shortcut
which allows me with a single click to
actually email or start a video chat
with someone doesn't my friendly tequila
isn't showing us online yet so maybe
we'll try that in a little bit or
perhaps I'll just chat with my friend
Anand here
let me try that Ladykiller where are you
mmm still offline well let's just talk
to my friend anon here on video chat hey
and on how are you man it was sweet
really well sorry I'm not lady killer
I'm sure you're not hope you're having a
good time man better so I'll see you a
little bit later okay I just wanted to
make sure that everybody saw the the new
video chat technologists part of
honeycomb and maybe lady Keeler will
show up in a little while thanks man
yeah lady Keeler so isn't there well of
course there's probably no one in the
world that knows how much video is
capable of changing things changing the
world in itself than CNN so I'd like to
invite my colleague and friend Lois Gump
from CNN to show an amazing new
application that CNN has been building
using the honeycomb platform Lois coming
up
thank you here you go make sure we're
all set up here okay good morning
everyone I'm Lois Gump vice president of
mobile at CNN I'm here with Viola king
who heads up our I report group we're
really excited to be here this morning
to talk a little bit about a new
application we've been building we've
been hard at work on an Android app for
the tablet and it will be launching in
the near future for free in the Android
Market and we'd like to give you a
little sneak peek first of all I'd like
to share a bit of context there's no
secret that tablets are becoming a force
in the marketplace and are going to be
something we're watching throughout the
year and as part of this you know CNN
has decided that Mobile is a core
strategic priority as part of the
strategy of making sure that we meet
consumer needs on mobile we want to make
sure that we're there for Android users
around the world we've learned quite a
bit over time and what we're trying to
do is to take what we learned and put it
into a really compact package that goes
where consumers are so if you take a
look you can see what we refer to as the
broad sheet here it's a compilation of
content you can have as many as three
hundred and fifty stories in one sheet
however if you want to dig down into a
more focused thing you can go into the
left fragment there and it goes back to
what hugo was speaking to in terms of
dividing up the screen and then you can
pick a category or you can swipe from
left to right in addition to that when
you find a story you're interested in
you can just go in look at the content
and then keep on going and I have to
tell you based on some of the
experiences we're having and testing
this is an incredibly immersive
experience consumers love it and there's
a lot of time spent in the application
that's in many respects the core of the
apps because it's so rich and there's so
much to it however if you look at the
top in the action bar you will see both
an audio update and also live video and
the live video is something of course
that goes to the core of what CNN is all
about here you can see a live stream we
have live streaming video both from the
US and also internationally in this case
it's
of our coverage of the protests in Egypt
you can get a sense of what's going on
we cover both top stories and breaking
news and we take advantage of the HLS
capabilities of honeycomb as we're
delivering this it's really a stunning
experience now these are some of the
aspects of our traditional CNN coverage
but in addition to that we have an
element of the app that we're building
in related to I report and to share more
about that I'd like to introduce Lila
our report is an invitation to anyone in
the world to participate in the news and
today it's a community of about 3/4 of a
million people who share photos and
videos and stories of things that are
happening in their corner of the world
and today what I'm excited to show you
that for the first time I report will be
available on a tablet so let's take a
look at what we have first if you tap I
report in the action bar what you see
first is a gallery of the most recently
featured I reports on CNN they are right
now this is this is live so what you're
seeing is Super Bowls no helmets right
lots and lots of snow in the Midwest but
also we've very recently seen a video of
I witness video of protests in Cairo and
and flooding in Australia and what
people are actually seeing and all of
that gets woven in to CNN coverage all
over all over CNN platforms every day my
favorite piece of the app though really
is not just that you can see I reports
but you can actually contribute one
yourself so so you could imagine that
you're standing in the middle of a news
event and like this one right and what
you're seeing in front of you is
something that you just have to share
you have to show the rest of the world
so here in this CNN I report in the app
for Android you could choose that you
want to capture a photo or a video
pull up your camera that we just saw
line up your shot right you could choose
to use the front-facing camera if you'd
like to describe what you're seeing or
use the back facing camera to actually
capture the scene so we've got our we've
got
Thank You Steven we press okay right
just a little bit about what it is that
we're seeing press upload and then the
story goes right into CNN and it gets
attached to your account on CNN I report
you'll also notice that in the in the
honeycomb status bar at the bottom of
the screen you're seeing a tiny little I
report icon that's indicating to you
that your story is being posted to I
report right now but if you'd like to
you can move on to something else you
could close the app and your story will
still make its way to CNN um so I I have
to say the thing that I'm most excited
about is that when I report is on this
tablet it means that it extends the
invitation to everyone to be part of the
news to a whole new audience of people
and I just I can't wait to see what they
do with it
so thanks so much Lila appreciate your
describing that what a powerful way to
connect the news to individuals and and
for certain people who want to to feel
part of it if you're in Chicago and
you're middle of the snow you can still
tap into this event and likewise if
we're here in the valley we can still
take a look and understand what's going
on in the Midwest now if we pan back a
little bit and look at the whole package
what we'll have is an application that
launches on the zoom tablet in the near
future in an edition will be available
on other tablets using the honeycomb
platform as they roll out around the
world and that's really exciting to us
at CNN I actually was just sitting next
to someone here who said hey you know
CNN is really well known as a video
platform a source of video and that's
absolutely true but the combination of
the video and the traditional reporting
and the imagery together it's just quite
powerful and so as people use tablets
and as these grow around the world we
want to be there and people when people
want to connect with the news we want to
be with them around the world so thanks
very much for sharing your time with us
Thank You Louis that was really amazing
let's just do a little bit more
multitasking here I'm reconnecting
because I'm told our friend Ladykiller
wants to try and call in we'll see if
that happens in a little bit but well
let me just segue to the rest of the
presentation here and if lady Keeler
calls in we'll take the call so
hopefully what you saw today was a
really good illustration of the hard
work that we've put into making sure
that honeycomb is an amazing story for
developers which we think it is we think
it opens incredible opportunities for
innovation in this new class of devices
we certainly cannot even predict what
you develop the developer community are
going to build of course the platform is
just one half of the story the other
half of the story is how to get these
applications these amazing applications
into the hands of users of people and to
tell that half of the story I want to
invite my colleague and friend Chris
yerga who's Android engineering director
for cloud services Chris state is yours
thank you thank you very much Hugo so if
a Ladykiller calls in can I speak with
that okay so Hugo's talk to you about
some of the improvements were making in
honeycomb we're also making some
important changes to Android Market that
I'd like to tell you about the changes
we're making we're doing so in order to
meet the needs of both users and
developers for users to give them the
best experience a variety of ways to
discover applications and also very
seamless path to purchasing those
applications and installing them on your
their devices for developers we want to
give them additional control over how
they promote their applications as well
as giving them some more flexible ways
to monetize those applications I'm going
to be talking about all of those things
here today the first thing that I'll be
announcing is something I'm very excited
about and while I'm logging in here I
would like to just reiterate something
that Andy Rubin said at the outset I'm
actually fairly new to Android fairly
new to Google
been here three months but I've been in
the industry for 20 years I've never
worked with a team that is as dedicated
and hardworking as the Android team and
the team that are putting together the
things that I'm showing here today I've
been working tirelessly to get them
ready for you and so I just want to give
some a bit of a shout out to them
so the first thing I'm happy to announce
today is the release of the Android
Market web store the Android Market web
store is basically the the new way that
users can get applications on their
devices up til now you're the way you
would browse applications and install
them is by using the Android Market
client on your phone but now with the
today's release of the Android Market
web store users can go to their browser
discover and browse through the entire
catalog of Android applications on
Android Market as well as install and
purchase directly to their device from
the web so let's take a look so as we've
been building Android Market we've kept
in mind that there's a variety of
different ways that users discover
applications sometimes I'm coming to the
market and I might not actually have
something very specific that I'm looking
for I'm more in a browsing mood right so
what I want to do is I want to come to
the store and have a variety of
different kinds of content sort of
offered up to me that I can easily
search through the homepage of Android
Market on the web delivers exactly that
as you can see here from the top we have
a carousel that shows a variety of
promotional banners for applications
that cycles through I can click through
them and see the different apps here
additionally underneath you'll see the
familiar categories from Android Market
on your device featured applications as
well as top paid and top free and
additionally we have categories that can
be browsed on the left-hand side but I
think I'm going to take a look here
through some of the featured
applications and see if there's anything
that catches my eye you know I'm sure
Kenny Chesney's a terrific singer but
that's not really the kind of app I'm
looking for but hey this Saniya actually
is catching my eye
so if I click in here it takes me to the
Applications detail page for this app
and so the first thing you'll notice is
that the page is graphically rich and it
looks terrific and it looks terrific in
a way that developers can control in
anticipation of launching Android Market
on the web we've enabled features for
developers that enable them to upload
these high resolution banners to promote
their applications as well as the larger
size icons over here on the left and so
by doing so developers are able to make
sure that when people come and look at
their applications on the Android Market
website they look their best
additionally you'll see here on the left
since this developer has other
applications in android market they show
up here so that folks can easily find
that and then all the information a user
needs to make a decision about whether
this is an interesting application for
them is on the page we have a
description user reviews as well as
application screenshots that I can look
at and so having look at this screenshot
this actually does look like a pretty
cool app I think I'm gonna purchase it
and install it onto my device I'd like
to show you how seamless that is so
there's a Buy button right here on the
page when I click on it it opens up this
window that pops up shows me the
permissions for the app ask me if I
which device I want to install too since
I only have one device registered to
this account its pre-populated for me
but if I had multiple devices and
tablets etc this list would be filtered
to just those devices that are
compatible with this application so I'm
going to go ahead and purchase it and by
clicking on the continue button here it
brings me I dismissed
instead of continue here
clicking on continue it brings up a
purchase dialog here and essentially all
I need to do with one additional click
is complete my purchase however I'm
gonna put this on the Google corporate
card that okay Andy
so I complete my purchase and it starts
charging my credit card and so the the
this is where some of the real cloud
magic happens because as its processing
my order as soon as that credit card
transaction completes what happens is if
we switch over here to my phone you can
see that I've got a notification right
up here and the application is already
downloading directly to my phone so this
works the same way that all of our
Google cloud powered services work
there's no wires there's no synching
with computers none of that sort of
nonsense
everything is connected your phone's
connected to the cloud your your Android
Market browser is connected to the cloud
and so everything just works seamlessly
syncing between the two and so now just
in a few short seconds here I actually
have the game successfully installed on
my Nexus phone so that's one way of
discovering applications but frequently
in addition to browsing through a
marketplace I often get recommendations
from my friends
about applications I should look at and
so the Android Market website enables a
lot of scenarios around this that are
very fast and flexible and easy I'd like
to show some of them to you so I
recently had lunch with a buddy of mine
Randy and he was recommending a
newsreader app that he thought I should
check out so he sent me this email here
and if I click on the the link that he
grabbed right off the Android Market web
site it takes me directly deep linked to
the applications details page for this
pulse newsreader app so I guess it turns
out that Randy and I have a similar
taste in apps because this is an
application I've already installed and
Android Market website knows that this
is already installed on my device and
tells me that here another thing that is
interesting here is that in addition to
the screenshots and banners this
developer has uploaded a YouTube video
to promote
their application so we've also been
enabling features on the Android Market
publisher site to enable developers to
upload YouTube videos as another way to
flexibly promote their applications and
get their message across to users when
they're here on the Android Market
website so since I have used this
application and I really do like it I
would like to share it with my friends
as well but instead of sending an email
I think I'm gonna tweet about it to my
followers on Twitter and so if you
notice here on the right hand side
there's a tweet button if I click on
this it pops up a little dialog from
Twitter its pre-populated with the link
already pre shortened to the application
on Android Market on the web and so I
can customize the link here and send it
out to my followers on Twitter and as
soon as that's completed it'll show up
on Twitter and anybody who gets that
message can then click on it and be
taken directly to the Android Market web
store so I can pop over to Twitter here
and show you how this shows up in my
stream and there's something kind of
cool about the way these links work so
if I click on the link for my computer
no surprise takes me right back to the
Android Market web site where I was but
the other thing I want to do is go over
here to my phone and show you how the
phone experience works these links do
the appropriate thing if you're either
on your Android device or if you're on
your browser here and so as we see here
my tweet just showed up so I can click
on that hello one and follow the link
and when I do follow this link what
happens is that it understands that this
is a link to an application on Android
Market and so it takes me directly to
the Android Market client on my phone
which is a more convenient way for me to
install this application from my mobile
device so the final way that people get
applications is sometimes you have a
pretty good idea of what it is exactly
you're looking for you might know the
specific application or you might have
an idea of the kind of application
you're looking for in this case my
family and I are planning a trip to
Japan my daughter is already
studying Japanese and she's been telling
me that I have to brush up on my
katakana so I'm gonna search for
katakana here on the Android Market
website when I do I get a list of
relevant search results from all the
applications on Android Market but I
also have some additional options here
about how I can present this list I can
elect to show only paid or free apps or
the combination of both I can also
filter by applications that are
compatible with specific devices that I
own in my case I'm kind of curious to
see what other users have found useful
so I'm going to sort by popularity here
and this looks interesting so I'm going
to go ahead and go in here and since
this is a free application installing it
on my phone is merely a one-click
process of clicking on the install
button and once again it starts
automatically downloading to my phone
having downloaded a number of
applications there's one final thing I'd
like to show you here which is the my
market account screen so when I go into
my market account it presents a list of
all the applications that I've
previously purchased so that I could do
things like click on them and install
them to an alternate device if I got a
new phone or a new tablet I can also go
into my settings page here and give a
nickname to individual devices so if I
have like the personal phone and a work
phone I can keep those keep easier track
of them so that I know which
applications are going to which devices
so that's the Android Market website it
is live right now on the internet so we
encourage everybody to come to market
Android comm and see the great work that
the team has been doing so the next
thing I want to talk about is related to
how users purchase applications so
Android has a global base of both users
and developers but currently in Android
Market if a user is purchasing an
application in a currency that's
different from the one that the
developer is selling in the currency
gets converted based on an exchange rate
and so it can be a bit of a confusing
experience for the user sometimes the
prices are you know funny numbers and
developers also kind of feel like you
know they want to remove some of that
confusion as well as have a little bit
more control over how their applications
are priced in different currencies so
today we're announcing that buyer
currency support is coming to Android
Market what this means is that in the
developer console when developers upload
their applications for the currencies
that are supported they can go in and
enter explicit prices for various
currencies that way it gives the user a
consistent experience gives the
developer a little bit more control over
how their applications are priced in
different markets the way we're rolling
this out is in a phased manner so what's
gonna happen is today the developer
console is going to turn on and for the
initial set of currencies for US sellers
the developers will be able to go in
there and set those override prices if
they wish to if they don't then
everything continues working the same
way it does today and then over the
coming months we'll be adding new
currencies and new seller supports now
the final thing and Ladykiller still
hasn't called so you know the final
thing I want to show today is something
that's very exciting to us here at
Android Market we've gotten a fair
amount of consistent feedback from
developers that they would like to have
additional ways to monetize their
applications on Android Market so I'm
very pleased to announce that support
for in-app purchases is coming to
Android Market applications now what
this means is that developers who
integrate with our in-app purchasing SDK
will be able to sell a variety of
virtual goods directly from within their
applications so examples could be a game
might sell additional levels or
consumables or even virtual currency
that could be used in game other
applications might use this to unlock
features or premium versions of the
applications I mean there's really a
wide variety of different ways in app
purchasing can be used by developers
we're very excited to see how they use
it we've been working with a couple
initially to get some feedback on the
in-app purchasing SDK and also to get
some integrations going to see how the
what they do with it and so I'm very
happy to invite one of them up on stage
here with me today I'd like you all to
welcome Bart de creme he is the general
manager of Disney mobile and he's got
some exciting news about their support
of Android Market and what they've done
with the in-app purchasing SDK all right
thanks Chris I'm Bart although I think
some of you know me better by my
nickname
Ladykiller anyway it's really great to
be here for the announcement today I
think at Disney we're a really good
example of what's going on on mobile
today we're bringing some of the most
beloved brands and characters and
stories to a new generation of mobile
devices that are just really powerful
and fun and just generally awesome and a
Disney mobile to date we've had about
somewhere over 60 million app downloads
already on other platforms and I think
now that we're coming to Android that
numbers about to get a lot bigger so
today I'm really excited to announce
that for the first time ever we're
bringing three of our key apps to the
Android platform first Radio Disney
Radio Disney not a lot of kids and
tweens in the audience here today but
it's really a bit of a phenomenon with
with young kids and with tweens in the
US but really all around the world and
with the new Radio Disney app you'll be
able the kids will be able to stream
music straight to their Android device
and they'll be able to talk back send
out shoutouts and song requests to Radio
Disney that's already been downloaded
millions of times on other platforms and
now we're bringing to androids we're
demoing it in the other room and it'll
be launching over the next couple of
weeks the second app that we're bringing
to to Android and that that'll be the
spring is jelly car and and some of you
may be familiar with jelly car it's one
of the most popular apps that we
originally developed for mobile at
Disney
it's
the original physics game which is of
course become a really big category over
the last year and what you do is you
tilt and you tap and you pinch your
phone to navigate your car through a set
of obstacles to the next level and so it
really takes advantage of all the
capabilities of these Android devices
with our that's also other app that has
been downloaded millions of times and
where we see we think we're gonna see
really big numbers on Android and then
finally I'm especially delighted having
worked on this with the team for three
years now to announce that we'll be
bringing Tap Tap Revenge to Android as
you may know that that revenge is our
most successful franchise and I think
it's one of the most popular apps ever
on any mobile platform and now we're
bringing it in its full glory to Android
with all the social features all the
gameplay and then most importantly all
the music that that is so powerful for
our audiences so we've got Lady Gaga
Katy Perry Linkin Park Bruno Mars in the
game and and Tap Tap Revenge has been
downloaded somewhere north of 50 million
times right now and we've sold more than
25 million songs in our in app platform
across across these different versions
of the game and and because giving our
users the music that they love and the
hits that they love is so critical to
the user experience in Tap Tap Revenge
we've waited until the announcement here
today of in-app billing to bring that
type revenge to androids so let's see
what it looks like we can switch to the
two device there we go
so here I'm running tap tap revenge on a
Nexus S but you can run it on any y vga
android device that's running Android
2.1 or higher and as you can see this is
the latest version of that type revenge
it's it's its depth average for and
we're showing us some of the big hits
here on the home page and what I'm gonna
do is I want to get some Bruno Mars so
we'll tap on the icon and it'll take you
to our store that's inside the app and
then all you do is you tap to purchase
the track panic and this is the new
in-app purchasing UI from Android and as
you see you see the price which which we
specify as a developer and then the user
has the credit cards that they've
entered or carrier billing that's
available for that device and and you
just you can just leave the to the
default or you can change it and then
I'm going to tap on the Buy button and
and here goes the in-app purchase
transaction and and there it is
I just purchased a Bruno Mars and so
we've pre-loaded it here for the demo so
I can simply click here now to go ahead
and play the song and the song that I'm
loading is again it's Bruno Mars he's
really the biggest new music sensation
of the year came out of nowhere
has had two big big hits and this is a
new song by him and it's called
somewhere in Brooklyn and let's see how
well I do with the device would have
flat on a table
Bruno Mars has been nominated for I
think it's seven Grammy Awards and the
Grammys are coming up in just a week so
you'll be hearing a lot more of him
we're not right so far it seems it has
an easy level actually achieved a little
bit that way so that staffed up revenge
on Android and it's coming this spring
with the launch of in-app billing on
androids thank you thanks a lot
so if I remember correctly we just gave
you access to the SDK fairly recently
how long did it take you to get this
working yeah well we've had a team of
developers working on the Android
version of that beverage for several
months now and that's been a really
great experience and and the people we
have working on this are very talented I
think we got the gold drop the latest
code for in-app billing I think we got
it just five days ago so great talented
engineers but really a great codebase
where the integration was really easy
for us to do that's terrific thank you
very much thank you Chris
so today we're going to be releasing
developer documentation for in-app
purchasing as well as sample code and
we're as I said we've been working with
a few developers to give some early
feedback on it now we're gonna release
it to the entire Android developer
community seeking to get some additional
feedback on the SDK and we're going to
be releasing it live to users prior to
the end of this quarter so there's been
a lot of stuff we've talked about today
I think it's about time to wrap up Hugo
there's some guys looking at me from
your tablet
oh it's Ladykiller let's switch over can
we get there we go hot here yeah
hey CeeLo yo how are you man thanks for
joining us no problem hey we're we're
just we're just calling to say that
we're really looking forward to seeing
at the Grammys next week we heard you're
performing with winneth and the Muppets
that sounds pretty awesome yeah oh
that's awesome man and what
threw up to just that little touring
that sounds like us on this end man
we're having a ton of fun and working at
the same time you're probably weren't
any harder than us though hey Cee Lo all
the best next week man thanks for
joining us thank you for having me
yeah talk to you soon man later hey
peace alright so thanks everyone for
coming I would now like to invite you to
come into the back and look at our demo
stations where we have 18 developers
showing off applications optimized for
honeycomb in-app billing and all the new
features we've announced today and for
those of you who are coming to Mobile
World Congress in Barcelona later this
month we're gonna have over 50
developers showing off honeycomb
optimized apps their developers have
really been the fuel behind a lot of
Android success and we think this year
is gonna be bigger and better than ever
with these announcements thank you very
much